you're suffering
they've lost
you can't protect them
gods of the universe
i come here to raise an army
today we'll go down in history
how exciting today we'll fight
i'm gonna kill this guy looks
probably like a true thought
this ends here and now i'm counting on there
here we go first shot of the day
this guy over here is going to direct
just for one day and then we're going
to see how he goes experience exciting
it's love and thunder
it's just so loud and in your face and flamboyant
it's always really fun working with taika
it's been an absolute disaster but
that's just the way it is on my films
taika is like a big kid sort of genius child
this this imagination is second to none
taika is a very bloody original
filmmaker he's mind-blowingly
talented this movie is just going to double
down on ragnarok how vibrant the worlds are
wanted to have fun tell a big story
but also showcase this emotion and this heart
that taika can do i think taika is really
good at reflecting the way life can be dark and
comedic all at once that we wanted to make a
crazy space invention but also something that's
emotional it means something you ever feel lost
look into the eyes of the people
that you love my uh sensing feelings
well you're right taika brought such a new
energy not just to the marvel universe but
to this franchise it certainly has everything
comedy drama action there's never a dull moment
when we first came up with love and
thunder we thought yeah the fans
will really freak out about this
i love you all and that is a wrap
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
thor love and thunder trailer video there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs a couple really
cool brand new scenes that we need to talk
about and a couple of cool deleted scenes
that are really hardcore that won't be in
the movie that they already talked about
that i'll explain during the video too
we're doing a giveaway for imax tickets for
the movie all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and just leave all your theories
about what happens on the video i'm supposed to be
screening the movie pretty soon if i get a chance
to see it early i will post my review on tuesday
when they allow it but my full post credit scene
video easter eggs breakdown for the entire movie
won't post till later in the week after it comes
out in theaters wide for everyone but the first
trailer starts with gorr talking to thor about
understanding all of his tragic history all the
people he lost basically him understanding the
events of avengers infinity war vander sand game
losing all those people like his mother you see
his mother's dead body all these flashbacks here
the death of his version of loki but remember he
doesn't know about the version of loki that's a
variant during the loki's series it'll be fun to
see him learn about that it'll just blow his mind
gorr doesn't have any special extra power to see
into someone's actual past like he's not actually
seeing his trauma it just sounds like he knows
about some of the stuff that thor has been through
and understands him like we have both experienced
loss in our lives just all part of movie gorr's
backstory and why it is that he went on his quest
to kill all the marvel gods they explained the
backstory in the movie will be a little bit
different from the gorr comics but basically
it's the same idea he was this really devout
worshiper of his own people's gods their pantheon
something terrible happened to his family that he
learned was avoidable and he blamed his gods for
not intervening and helping out thinking that they
didn't care about them so he doesn't think they
deserve to exist then he's able to find the power
of the necro sword in the movie that comes from
the shadow realm this place here where it seems
like there's no color except the stuff that's
coming off of the god tier weapons in the gods
themselves like thor like he's generating color
in this black and white space so the first group
of gods that he kills are his own people's gods
and then he goes around to the other pantheons
one by one kind of doing the thanos avengers
infinity war thing before he got the infinity
stones balancing one planet at a time balancing
one pantheon at a time perfectly balanced is all
universes should be but when he's telling thor he
can't protect them he's probably talking about the
other gods that thor is trying to prevent him from
killing like gorr doesn't want to kill regular
people that's his whole thing is that he starts
out on this quest to kill these gods it seems like
a noble quest because most the gods that he does
wind up killing are pretty terrible people but to
make a batman christian bale reference eventually
he becomes the villain of the story without
completely realizing what he's turned into
you either die hero or live long enough to see
yourself become the villain and boom he became the
villain when you hear thor's appeal to the other
gods of the universe to raise an army to fight
gorr it sounds like that's actually happening at
omnipotent city when he's making his plea to zeus
and all the other gods of the godhead here like
look we need to band together and kill this person
you also see some different scenes of zeus and
thor together that are part of this larger scene
that are just different from what we see in the
trailers because eventually they do have to get
zeus's lightning bolt so either he winds up dying
or he just winds up giving them the lightning bolt
temporarily like lending them his power because
it seems like later in the trailer thor is using
zeus's lightning bolt to grant god tier power to
all these other figures here so this might be a
version of the god bomb scene from the gorr comics
all these other people here just might be lesser
gods that gorr has captured and is forcing to help
him build his version of the movie's god bomb and
when i say god bomb it's like whatever his final
plan winds up being it might not be an actual bomb
in the version of the movie but in the comics
gorr basically has his own version of a thanos
infinity gauntlet storyline like thanos has
to balance the universe one planet at a time
until he gets the infinity gauntlet with all six
infinity stones gore has his own version of that
and that basically is the god bomb that allows
him to kill all the rest of the mcu gods in one
fell swoop at the same time so it just seems like
thor is sharing some of this god tier power with
these other figures here you also notice they've
upgraded the cg in the later trailer some of the
scenes look way different way better they show
him seeing that gorr has killed his friend this
giant rat looking god from the gore comics it's a
scene right out of the comics in the new versions
of the trailer you can see this gold color energy
floating off of it as it dies just like the energy
coming off of odin's body as he died during thor
ragnarok so what they might do because the same
gold energy is coming off of zeus's lightning bolt
and a lot of these scenes that seem like they're
happening later in the movie they might just say
that all gods give off this kind of cosmic energy
all these scenes with thor underground here in
this dark area seems that they're happening in
the same place the big chamber with all the
cosmic entities because you see gore's army
from the shadow realm running past the statue
of the living tribunal here there's also another
scene of him using the lightning bolt against
stormbreaker which is giving off the bifrost
in the same underground area the only reason why
he might be trying to stop stormbreaker in the
bifrost is because gore is using it as part of his
god bomb like whatever his final plan is for the
rest of the gods in the mcu it might be a version
of the comics where he basically forced his store
to help him but then thor's able to free himself
it just goes full on whoop ass on gore if you
remember the first thor movie loki tried to use a
version of that plot against yodenheim the planet
of the frost giants that he literally came from
the bifrost is basically like a wormhole through
space that allows them to travel super fast across
the universe but also because of the way it works
one of its side effects is that if you point it
through giant physical objects it becomes a super
powerful weapon so gore might be using the bifrost
as part of whatever his final solution is there's
also another scene of jane foster fighting gore in
the necro sword with thor's hammer making it seem
like the hammer itself is about as powerful as
the necro sword the really cool thing too is that
you get a wide shot of this underground chamber
and there's another giant head of another cosmic
entity this black and white head represents the
in-betweener in marvel comics the in-betweener
represents a lot of big cosmic ideas like life
and death reality illusion good evil logic emotion
nothingness god man it's supposed to be an agent
of lord chaos and master order like an aspect of
chaos and order at the same time the reason why
half of its faces gold and the other half is black
is the gold half is kind of like the white half
in the comics that represents the forces of order
in the black half represents the forces of chaos
that's basically what's going on with all the
other cosmic entities in this chamber they're
meant to be so powerful and so ancient that they
represent ideas given form if you're a fan of
a lot of that really cosmic storytelling they
get into that during the ultimates comic books
so maybe we'll see a version of that play out
in the movies at some point with a version the
ultimates forming there's a little new footage
of the guardians of the galaxy like nebula has a
leather ravagers jacket now the other cool easter
egg that a lot of you been asking about here too
is the hat that kevin feige is wearing with the
owl on it like there isn't any big references
to that during thor love and thunder because
it's actually a secret invasion reference there's
even scroll language written on the side so if you
think you can decode the scroll language written
on the side write it below in the comments we'll
get a separate trailer for marvel secret invasion
series later this year because it's going to be
airing next year in fact one of the cool deleted
scenes that we learned about that's not going to
be in the movie and i don't think that it's going
to be on the dvd it might wind up on the dvd
is actually lena heady played a version of hera
in the movie she was going to be zeus's wife as
part of all these omnipotent city scenes we also
learned about some other deleted scenes of thor's
friends so it sounds like gore went after eitri on
the dwarven home world the grand master on sakhar
he was supposed to be in the movie and it was like
a separate wtf deleted scene with gore mutilating
himself when he went on his mission to kill all
the gods like he was this really devout person
with a bunch of religious tattoos all over himself
and when he turned against the gods he mutilated
himself to get rid of all those markings kevin
feige was probably just like nope that's way too
hardcore can't put that in the movie but if
you spotted any brand new easter eggs in the
trailer that i didn't talk about in the video just
write them below in the comments i've got a bunch
of big thor videos that i'm working on for this
week obviously make sure you go see the movie as
soon as possible everyone click here for my new
black panther 2 first look at namor and some of
the other characters during the movie and click
here for that funny new ant-man video that just
leaked out thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!